the movie opens in a forest where an
elderly man is returning home after
fishing along the way he discovers a
large egg on the ground and approaches
it to take a closer look as he picks it
up Suddenly a hissing sound emanates
from nearby the man then turns around to
find a gigantic T-Rex standing behind
him both of them have a tense stare down
and the old man casually greets the
dinosaur in reply he gets a loud angry
Roar the scene then fast forwards by
five years and we are shown a laboratory
situated deep in the forest where some
scientists are conducting research on a
crocodile turns out that they are trying
to create a new species of Dinosaur by
combining the dnas of both types of
creatures meanwhile the head scientist
Richard enters the experiment room and
injects a serum into the crocodile
causing it to behave aggressively when
it starts getting out of control the
scientists have to reluctantly
tranquilize it this frustrates Richard a
lot as he has been trying to create a
dinosaur for years but all his efforts
have gone in vain if he doesn't find a
solution soon his funding will be cut
off dick better calm those Crocs in the
next scene some middle school students
visit a museum where they see dinosaur
fossils and Bones as the teacher
explains about Extinction a curious boy
named Chris asks if any relatives of
dinosaurs are still alive in reply the
teacher mentions Birds frogs and
crocodiles as distant relatives hearing
this Chris wonders if there might be a
large dinosaur still living somewhere
but his classmates laugh at him except
for his friends John and Carrie after
the museum trip as Chris is returning
home with his friends he notices a shop
called world of Wonders this makes him
curious so he enters the shop inside he
meets the owner who resembles the old
man from the beginning of the movie
initially the old man assumes Chris to
be a normal kid and suggests he go away
as there are no toys for him but when
our boy insists on being shown something
very strange and appealing the
shopkeeper brings out various antique
this excites Chris but he still wants to
see something extraordinary after
searching for a while the old man
finally presents a locked box promising
it holds something special he also makes
it clear that he doesn't want money but
only a promise to keep the Box safe
which Chris agrees to it better not be
Andy warhol's poo or a Furby afterward
Chris reaches home enters his room and
secretly opens the box he finds a large
egg the same one from the start of the
movie Chris then watches several online
videos on how to hatch the egg after
gaining enough information he sets up
the right conditions and covers the egg
with a blanket before leaving for lunch
with his parents after a while he
returns to his room and patiently waits
for the egg to hatch in just a few
minutes cracks appear on the egg and a
cute little dinosaur emerges from inside
Chris is completely taken aback as he
was under the impression that dinosaurs
were extinct as he tries to touch it the
little creature gets spooked and creates
a Ruckus inside the room it breaks ever
everything in its way and eventually
hides under the bed to lure the dinosaur
out from there Chris has an idea he
places some gummy bear candies in front
of the bed at first the dinosaur doesn't
pay much attention but eventually the
sweet
attempts it and it cautiously emerges
from its hiding spot Chris in a gentle
manner reassures the dinosaur that he
means no harm he starts petting its head
and the dinosaur begins to trust him
playfully exploring the room
it runs over to Chris's reading desk and
starts nibbling on his notebooks our boy
manages to take the notebook away from
the dinosaur's mouth and Promises to get
some proper food for it shortly after
when Chris returns from the kitchen he
notices the dinosaurs groan slightly in
size regardless he feeds it and then
names it after his favorite scientist
Hugh Hefner I mean Albert following this
they spend some time playing with a ball
later when Chris's mom comes to check on
him he quickly hides Albert and pretends
to be going to bed his mother is
surprised but eventually leaves his room
the following day Chris heads to school
with Albert and his friends John and
Carrie also join him Chris hopes to keep
Albert hidden but the dinosaur has other
plants it sneaks out from behind Chris
and stands in front of his friends John
and Carrie are shocked to see the
dinosaur and start asking questions left
with no choice Chris shares the
incredible story of how he obtained an
egg from a store and hatched it into a
dinosaur as the three continue talking
they noticed that Albert has grown in
size again Chris then makes the decision
to skip school for the day and take
Albert to the old man's shop
unfortunately when he arrives there he
learns that the name of the shop is
changed it is now being run by an old
lady who claims that she works there
alone surprised Chris asks about The Old
Man and the lady reveals that he was her
late husband he mysteriously died five
years ago but the cause was never known
feeling puzzled Chris decides to take
Albert to the Dinosaur Museum to learn
more about him there once they reach it
he talks to the receptionist and
requests to meet the person in charge in
response she asks him to wait a while
and explore the museum until the head of
the museum arrives eventually the chief
scientist Richard arrives at the Museum
he is here to collect some more fossil
samples to extract Dino DNA for his
research while Chris is busy exploring
Albert manages to escape from his bag
and starts hopping around the dinosaur
fossils on display a curious girl and
her mother noticed Albert but they
mistake him for a robotic dinosaur so
there's no chaos however Richard spots
Albert through a CCTV camera and rushes
to capture him for research that chase
unfolds within the museum with the
dinosaur darting around Chris eventually
catches Albert and puts him back in his
bag unfortunately as he's about to leave
dick catches up to them and questions
Chris about the bag's contacts desperate
to protect his new friend Chris runs
away without giving an explanation on
the way as Albert's hunger grows Chris
heads to the supermarket to buy him some
food unfortunately inside the store a
dog notices Albert and starts chasing
him frightened the dinosaur runs through
the store creating a complete mess he
eventually escapes and hides in the back
of a car later the car's owner returns
and drives away come completely unaware
that Albert is inside Chris notices this
at the last moment but is unable to
catch up to the car upon reaching home
the car owner discovers Albert who has
now grown in size significantly turns
out he ate all the food items kept in
the trunk of the car the frightened
owner mistakes him for a monster and
tries to shoot him but Albert somehow
manages to escape after a while the man
calls the police and informs them about
the dinosaur they arrive in no time and
capture Albert thinking he's a large
lizard they then contact Richard he's
the reptile expert in town Chris also
notices the cops capturing his friend
and follows them to the police station
in the next scene he reaches the station
and finds Albert in a cage noticeably
larger now as he contemplates on how to
help his friend he meets an old man
bearing a striking resemblance to the
one who gave him the egg the man asks
why he's here and Chris explains to him
the entire predicaments surprisingly the
old man promises to help and also
advises him to take Albert to a larger
space like the forest or the inside of
Elon musk's ego Chris agrees to follow
his suggestions but is unsure about how
to proceed soon Richard and his team
arrive and take Albert away in their van
as they depart Albert looks back at
Chris with a sense of sadness once
they've left the old man brings a
two-seater Buggy car and asks Chris to
get in together they set off for the lab
in the most unconventional of ways along
the way Chris's dad briefly spots him
but dismisses it as a hallucination well
they did warn me that LSD never leaves
the system at the lab Richard delivers a
self-congratulatory speech to his team
before taking Albert inside meanwhile
Chris and the old man use Nitro boosters
to reach the lab faster but they
discover the car has no brakes
attempting to stop it they decide to use
an anchor rope but the plan fails as
they forget to attach the end rope to
the car finally the old man manages to
stop the car by crashing it into a tree
afterward the duo reaches the lab which
is heavily guarded by many security
Personnel the old man then suggests
Chris go and find Albert while he
distracts the guards he then approaches
them and pretends to perform some magic
meanwhile Chris sneaks into the lab and
searches around for Albert after a bit
of looking around he eventually finds
him locked in a cage he appears to have
grown into a full-sized Dinosaur by now
suddenly two guards arrive at the scene
and prepare to attack Chris but out of
nowhere the old man also shows up and
quickly incapacitates the guards Chris
then takes the keys from one of the
Fallen guards and frees Albert however
when they attempt to run out of the
place the chief scientist and his team
surround them Richard orders his men to
lock up the trio but to his dismay the
guards are terrified of Albert's immense
size they simply don't want to go near
him seeing this Richard reassures his
team not to fear the dinosaur but at the
same time Albert Roars loudly and flees
into the forest with Chris and the old
man desperate to get the dinosaur for
research and experimental purposes rich
did his team follow them armed with guns
after they reached the heart of the
forest the old man takes Chris and
Albert inside a cave to seek Refuge the
chief scientist shouts offering Chris
money in exchange for Albert's surrender
but our boy immediately declines
asserting his responsibility to care for
Albert at this moment the old man
convinces Chris that the forest is the
safest place for Albert to live happily
He suggests that they should leave him
here initially Chris refuses to let his
friend go but after a bit of thinking he
realizes the importance of natural
habitat in Albert's life and reluctantly
agrees he then bids farewell to the
dinosaur expressing his love and care
I'm getting Pikachu flashbacks right now
but this Albert Ventures deeper into the
forest while the old man and Chris head
out as soon as they arrive on the main
road Richard and his team surround them
demanding to know Albert's whereabouts
in reply Chris assures them that Albert
is safe and will be living his remaining
life freely suddenly a police car
arrives causing Richard and his team to
flee the sheriff then asks Chris and the
old man about their destination and
offers them a ride to return to the city
in the next scene the duo sits outside
the same shop where Chris got the egg he
expresses his gratitude to the old man
for saving his friend right then John
and Carrie arrive there inquiring about
Albert's whereabouts Chris informs them
that Albert is gone and turns to
introduce them to the old man however to
his surprise the old man has vanished
earlier Chris had asked him if he was a
ghost and the old man had said nope I
just wanted to get away from my wife
confused Chris peers inside the shop and
sees the old man raising his hand before
slowly fading away this makes him
realize that the old man is a ghost
whose main purpose was to save Albert
the movie then ends with Albert's Roar
echoing through the forest he is now
safe and free far from All the Troubles
of the city subscribe for more videos
like this turn turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching